Michael how would you compare and
contrast kickstarter to indy gogo and
would you give the edge to indigo then
uh they're very different now
Kickstarter IndieGoGo I mean when they
first started it was kind of like it's
just new platform for funny movies and
whatnot I think through time they've
kind of separated a lot Kickstarter
obviously is probably a little more
mainstream I just from people I know
talking to them they may feel a little
more comfortable not so much anymore
with Kickstarter just because it's known
a little more on the press and all that
I us I I don't know their goals or where
they're going but I feel like they're
really separating and kicks in indy gogo
is kind of the the place where you go
where you're you know the indie spirit i
should say is alive an IndieGoGo and
it's and socially to they do a lot of
social campaigns that work well
Kickstarter seems much more now like I
say it's pre-sales now they don't really
I don't know they don't do so much p
cells and movies anymore but it's kind
of it's kind of going i know the
kickstart people probably don't like
that because if they sent messages and
all that like hey you know where a
donation based in sight but i think the
because of Kickstarter's mainstream
success they've attracted you know
certain companies are acting like the
video games industrial design tech
companies which aren't there so already
fully funded they're not like a little
movie where it's like hey we're gonna go
shoot this little movie and hopefully
will turn out good and it's just us and
we're kind of artists um not that video
game people aren't artists by enemies
but you know it's it's it's in their
business plan illness in a way as we're
IndieGoGo still is a kind of independent
and and you know we need your money to
make this movie whereas the other things
are kind of we oh yeah we just want to
cut off some of our losses before we
release IE video game or whatnot so but
they both have good and valid points I
would probably our dogs are a little
more mainstream so I think Kickstarter's
a little better way to go for
ads within the movies we do or so for
such a limited audience that it's like
yeah you know and it's it's the movies
such as when we're doing now is it's all
people just doing them because they want
to do the movie you know there's no
other real goal like you know all the
actors kind of really like the concept
and they want to do the movie because of
the concepts / any kind of success they
see in the future well who's the
audience for love touch heat vision it's
such a tough answer to say through the
audience for the movie is because it's a
very I think on the omelet the actual
movie is very I think audience-friendly
it's a it's a bittersweet comedy there's
elements a comedy it's a father-son
story which we don't really talk about
in the campaign because it's just too
much to put in a little video the
initial conceits of the movie could be
mainstream but it could be very very
indie and my take on it it's a very very
indie take because I'm just I'm
exploring something and it's not the not
the the way the Hollywood movie would
probably be in terms of structure so
it's a kind of a tough thing to say I
think you know the audience is pretty
pretty small but the people who actually
show up to watch the movie would
probably like it a lot that makes sense
you